the military has come a long way in the
past two decades
at the turn of the millennium you could
be sacked from the forces for being gay
lesbian or bisexual
now such candidates are actively
encouraged to apply alistar joined up in
the late 90s
and was forced to repress his sexuality
the
atmosphere in the background looking
back could have been perceived as quite
dark
the language was quite discriminatory
and
it had felt for anybody who had wanted
to be themselves potentially there was
no opportunity for them to
to be able to he believes today's
anniversary of the ban being lifted
is an opportunity to celebrate the
progress that's been made i've been open
myself
within my unit since 2006 so we're
talking
14 years and the individuals knew me
before that
they knew i hadn't changed since the
armed forces no longer cares
what you do in your own private life so
long as you are a dedicated individual
to your job
it's not known how many people were
affected by the restrictions over the
years
because many quit or were discharged
without the true reason being recorded
but campaigners say the military has
made real progress in its treatment of
lgbt
people now we've got to a stage 20 years
later where actually
all three of our military services are
ranking within stonewall's top 100
employers we know that they've made
efforts with the policies that they
produce with their community engagement
to actually attract lgbt staff into
those services
under fire no one cares if you're gay
or straight just that the soldier the
sailor or the airman next to you has got
your back
a reception was held in parliament on
thursday ahead of today's milestone
at the event a government minister
publicly apologized for the ban
calling it unacceptable military
charities say it created years of pain
and hurt for many service personnel
and their families the ministry of
defense hopes its positive work in the
years since
means the forces are now more inclusive
and accepting
than ever before get bradshaw sky news